hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday June 26 2017 what's going on how
[Music]
how you doing how are you doing this
[ __ ] Monday morning cut is global
woman making your ruffed hot climate
change
let's give it a nicer name so when we
going to use you as a euphemism huh
photosynthesis Jesus Christ see the
photosynthesis [ __ ] police there's
nothing people enjoy more on the
Internet other than jerking off to
people sold into the sex industry
sexually what do they call human
trafficking is [ __ ] correcting
somebody jesus [ __ ] christ the amount
of gold I give you F God from [ __ ]
bid a pasty [ __ ] dope like me makes a
mistake every once every [ __ ] five
minutes on a podcast all of you [ __ ]
[ __ ] cannot wait to go on the internet
and just read me the riot act like like
you're up for some sort of [ __ ] award
in the science industry you know
whatever the [ __ ] they call it the
science circuit so they always call
radio guys say then ya day you're
working the circuit you mean doing the
road I didn't realize there was a
circuit everybody [ __ ] coming at me
photosynthesis yeah I did I think you
meant pollination laughing my ass off
you know jesus [ __ ] christ let me
even let me look it up right now paul
nation today
paul nation why they never been a ball
playing in that pollination is the
process by which pollen is transferred
to the female reproductive organs of a
plant thereby enabling fertilization to
take place like all living organisms
seed plants have a singer made single
major goal to pass their genetic
information on to all right well how the
[ __ ] does it get there
that's pollination I like I said
photosynthesis alright so that's what
the photosynthesis was okay here we go
photosynthesis that doesn't have a good
ring pollination photosynthesis
I tell you have to bring them up now
batting number 22 that's more like an
MMA fighting out of the red corner you
can see I guess what we just read the
definition fighting another red corner
the process by which green plants and
some other organisms use sunlight to sit
decide the food there's no reading from
carbon dioxide to wall and water the
process by which green plants and some
other organisms use sunlight to
synthesize foods from carbon dioxide and
water would have synthesized me see this
is what happens are they using autotune
synthesize sy sy is photosynthesize you
know I meant all rights in the SIS
synthesize alright the combination of
ideas to form a theory or system well I
doesn't sound like a definition they
were looking for synthesis synthesis
I'll come on you [ __ ] [ __ ] plural
synthesis the formation of a chemical
compound through the combination of a
simple compound of illness see both of
you guys that knew that I use the wrong
word you couldn't [ __ ] tell me what
all this [ __ ] in it you know unless you
own a lab coat right photosynthesis the
process by which green plants and some
other organism uses use sunlight to
synthesize foods from carbon dioxide in
water like digest them turn them into
something edible so some contrite now
like oh yeah
shut up alright there you [ __ ] beaker
readin [ __ ] [ __ ] you and your black
frame glasses alright least I own my
work unlike you in the science industry
who owns your [ __ ] and what do they use
it for you're out there trying to feed
plants using sunlight right and all of a
sudden they come up with a new way to
send our Magic Mike set so I'm starting
to call our missiles Magic Mike that's
what we have in this country we got the
top of the line [ __ ] missiles you
know like the Mercedes and the Ferraris
in f1 top of the line we got the magic
Mike's we shoot them into the city they
only kill the bad people right all these
terrorist groups they like to [ __ ] in
the who's guys in the orange cars this
year their [ __ ] cars blow up every
goddamn [ __ ] race one of the goddamn
drivers does you know what [ __ ] you guys
I'm taking a race off and went to go
drive the Indy 500 he left Formula One
to drive a [ __ ] in d5 in an IndyCar
race in America the mclaren honda is
there like the terrorist group you know
what i mean you don't know what the
[ __ ] going to happen but we got the
Magic Mike Magic Mike photosynthesis
pollination whatever you guys got me I'm
the [ __ ] what's that guy yachties the
guy yatta you said blow me like a cello
or whatever I don't think I've ever
related to a rapper more in that moment
you know as white as I am that's what it
took you know not talking about this and
talking about that it's the fact that
that poor bastard thought a cello was a
wind instrument I was like you know what
this sounds like the kind of person that
I went to summer school with and you
know what I bet he has other talents
other than being able to memorize you
[ __ ] [ __ ] out they were they were
able to memorize what photosynthesis was
versus pollination can I ask you a
question seriously in all seriousness
where did it get you huh other than
getting to be some content a cocktail
party you know were you a socialite you
can talk photosynthesis and fashion you
know by the way thank you for Greg
to me I don't know how it's going to
affect my life but if there was just
something about the joy that people took
in in correcting me that I I took
umbrage with that I use that correctly
or is that the wrong you word you know
what you know what I like about Twitter
is I don't have to read anymore I'll
just say [ __ ] that I think is right you
guys can correct me right I'll learn
things you guys can feel better about
yourselves you know what Dad they could
say yeah it's a little [ __ ] when they
call little surf and turf little scratch
my back I scratch your back I don't know
what you see but Beyonce said she's got
a gig at the [ __ ] Hollywood Bowl
that's pretty what a [ __ ] talented
family you know what I mean
that's how talented that family is like
she can't even get anybody to look at
her at the Thanksgiving table because
they're [ __ ] older sister sold out
the Rose Bowl you know I mean she's like
the [ __ ] of the family because she
only sold out the Hollywood Bowl honey
honey honey quiet down quiet down your
sister is talking about what it was like
to be singing bootylicious as the
stealth bomber flew over the stage okay
was that wrong to do that
speaking of pollination will this get
the Beehive after me it was funny about
all of those [ __ ] groups they're so
up the ass of the artist I swear to god
she would [ __ ] she wouldn't take her
goddamn shoes off to run across the
street and make a [ __ ] emergency call
and one of those old telephones back in
the day let's just say there wasn't cell
phones if she saw one of you guys
sitting on the side of the road she
wouldn't give a [ __ ] about you what's
another one who's another one's got a
big following you know there was it's
the Beehive doesn't Mariah Carey have
one you don't I mean I don't know what
it is it's just I don't know what
there's something about
acting like a complete [ __ ] and
treating people like [ __ ] that just
women can't get enough a certain type of
woman they can't get enough of it what
is it why you know something I always
wondered if more women would like Ronda
Rousey or the current champion that I
don't know the name of my apologies if
more of them took like MMA could
actually beat the [ __ ] out of you would
they just not walk around being mean to
each other as much you know I think
that's Jenna means white guys aren't as
mean as women are because personally
speaking anyways because I know that 90%
of guys can beat the [ __ ] out of me
right but the very least land a couple
to my you know and I [ __ ] bruise like
the Irishman I am you know stop you know
two punches in I don't need that [ __ ] so
I try to basically you know mind my P's
and Q's what does that stand for hun you
[ __ ] brainiacs what does that stand
for let me find out like you know and I
have to fact-check to everything so I
don't get [ __ ] look at people with my
ass again
minding your P's and Q's mining your P's
and Q's P and Q origin or is it yes P's
and Q's not P and Q mind your P's and
Q's dick [ __ ] [ __ ]
I do not say that without your [ __ ]
[ __ ] what does mind your P's and Q's
come from this is going to be a very
special educational podcast it's just
going to be me alright okay if you've
ever been told to mind your P's and Q's
it might have struck you as a rather odd
thing to do that's a nice way of saying
it was annoying I think any time seven
say hey mind your P's and Q's I my
immediate thought was who the [ __ ] is
this guy
tell me to mind these things I won't sit
some 80s comedy telling me to mind thank
venogram
the concept seems reasonable enough
behaving behaving well not giving a
fence but quite but quite what the
letters P and Q have to do with this is
a little more mysterious why not B and D
of Jesus here's something
why not be a game all right now can you
just [ __ ] get a whole entry all right
either the whole [ __ ] this guy's just
you know some funny about these [ __ ]
[ __ ] who write for a living they
just can't get to it they feel if they
don't take up a whole [ __ ] page or
bill maybe there's people out there that
enjoy reading maybe it's that okay well
you know what I'll take the ride why not
be in D or mmm MN n or any other
combination sadly as it often is the
case with being more intriguing terms in
the English language there is no
definitive answer to the Oh what the
[ __ ] no one knows what it means this
last meeting we're like directed at the
dead mean queen and not Queen what the
best possible manners mind your dancing
I don't know the oxford dictionary
doesn't even know the answer you know
it's funny they don't even have the
[ __ ] answer yet they still they still
could they couldn't keep their mouths
shut could they I bet somebody else has
once somebody at this points the
internet somebody's going to take a
guess alright what does it mean ever
been told to mind your P's and Q's yes
that's why I'm here
once you're working a mechanical
printing press at the time chances are
you are fairly subtly being told to mind
your manners what exactly are your P's
and Q's the short answer is no one
really know why isn't that why isn't
that right there mind your P's and Q's
what does it mean and then BOOM nobody
knows what kind of a [ __ ] ass you
ever been told to mind your P's and Q's
well unless you are in a faint pres
[ __ ] two paragraphs you know what it
is because this is delving into the
world of people that that like to know
[ __ ]
so even when they don't know [ __ ] they
still have to [ __ ] write three
paragraphs on it alright [ __ ] all of
this
[ __ ] all it I was just frustrating um
anyways I am actually you know before I
looked up those things before I remember
that you guys corrected me you know
maybe you guys weren't being [ __ ]
maybe you're just trying to help me out
you know since I'm hanging around a
socialite
you know socially as far as I can tell
it's just a well read gold-digging [ __ ]
you know like how did you get there you
got to be married to somebody rich if
you just walk be just pleasant to be
around you don't really have a [ __ ]
job and somebody's got to be bringing
home the bacon right bring it on the
bacon where did that come from you know
compete unless you're unless you're a
farmer I don't know unless you you're
working unless you're a butcher I was 20
[ __ ] pair gets later point is nobody
really knows anyways I'm actually
relieved believe it or not because I did
the Big Papi roast on was it Thursday
night and thank Christ
it went about as great as it could have
gone I am NOT a big fan of doing roasts
you know what the last roast I did was I
did the Patrice O'Neal roast like 15
years ago or something whatever the hell
that was that was the last time because
I never understood doing one unless you
were friends with the person right but I
always like as always see guys like
Lenny clap indent and uh Dennis Leary
you know they're always hanging out at
Red Sox games getting up in the
broadcast booth and I'm like I would
love to [ __ ] do some [ __ ] like that I
need to do more Boston hometown [ __ ] so
this thing came up and I'm like uh why
did it have to be a roast and Mia chimed
in she's like so I said yes I'll do it
then I had no time to [ __ ] him right
because I was dealing with a bunch of
other [ __ ] and all of a sudden it was a
few days away and I dealt with that race
that race that roast the way this
country dealt with y2k you know what we
waited until the last second then we
oh my god what are we going to do like
we treated it like a [ __ ] giant term
paper that's what I did and it was a
race to Thursday what I was trying to
say a race to the finish line a race
against time and I actually figured out
how my brain works when it comes to
those [ __ ] things it's the same way
it works for stand-up but for some
reason you think like a roast I have to
sit down in write jokes that's not what
I need to do I needed to to put my dog I
had to put my daughter in the stroller
and walk around the block and then I had
to uh I smoked a cigar by myself on the
back porch and I just kept thinking [ __ ]
and I would just videotape myself saying
it and then I had all these videos and I
figured if I told you this guy's you
guys this ona oh sorry on Thursday but I
just watched the videos and I just
spliced together every good one just
transcribed them and then I had the
block of everybody right I had poppy
Gronk Pedroia Josh wolf
Lenny clack Sarah Tiana Anthony Mackie
and everybody that was on the [ __ ]
thing and I just would put them
underneath you know each name and then I
just then made a new document and I just
took the best of the best
slid them over then I put him in the
best possible order then I went in order
of person and then I smoothed it out and
and it all worked thank [ __ ] christ
the only way to make fun of David Ortiz
was just to make fun of how he looked in
the fact that he was a d H that's all I
had and I made fun of the Dominican
Republic a little bit and that was it
that was it so I don't know if his video
I know
Grunk [ __ ] killed Pedroia killed he
told this [ __ ] hilarious story about
poppy not knowing his first name was
Dustin somebody said to him like poppy
was in the batter's box not the batter's
box
was on like the on-deck-circle and
Pedroia was stepped out of the batter's
box umpire called timeout of something
and the catcher just said hello daddy
said hey what's up Dustin and when
Dustin walked over to poppy to talk to
him poppy said he goes what the [ __ ] did
that guy just say to you [ __ ] did that
guy just call you he he said he said
what's up Dustin and poppy was like what
the [ __ ] does that mean
because that's my first is my first name
bobby was like great oh yeah
like he didn't even know doesn't name
was being weak so Pretoria is like dude
it's my first name they introduced me
every time I go up to bat I've been
going up to bat like ten thousand times
I bat in front of you every time I come
to the plate they say now batting number
Dustin Pedroia and it just never clicked
with them there's another guy I would
have gone to summer school at Pedroia
got it like I think Pedroia got it the
worst he was hilarious he just kept
sitting there like dude what the [ __ ]
ever you know it was just I think he got
you know speaking of 11-thousand there
was like 11,000 short jokes for him so
there there is clips of it up on the
internet Dom it wasn't the greatest
organized thing was the first time they
did it and they didn't know how to do a
roast and he can't have people filming
at it because a roast is over the top
and that's how people get in trouble and
they you know they take [ __ ] out of
context and bla bla bla bla bla it's
completely [ __ ] over the top so you
know I don't know why I don't know why
they let people film I don't know why
things happen why did things happen like
that but anyways I had to go on dead
last and everybody [ __ ] killed Lenny
went up first killed Adam Ray went up
dressed as a Yankee fan named Tony and
just told everybody in the crowd to suck
his dick and kept trashing Big Papi and
then bragging about the Yankees 27
championships and the crowd loved it
while they were born and they also
loving it he was [ __ ] hilarious
Anthony Mackie killed Sarah Tiana
[ __ ] destroyed probably on my
favorite joke in the night and
[ __ ] gave Gronk went up killed then
Pedroia and then I had to go up last and
it's one of those things as you sit
there you know you're kind of losing
angles as you go so I tried to do I
tried to just go like a unique way
so with Gronk I knew everybody was going
to say he was stupid so I was like god
I'm going to say he's smart I'm going to
go that way with it by the way by the
way he actually was commenting on how he
hates going to concerts and everybody
sits there [ __ ] looking at the
concert through their phone you know
what I mean how [ __ ] stupid that is I
love everything said that guy's dumb you
know like you can make it to the NFL
memorize the playbook and all of that
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] you got to learn
and then go out on the field against the
top athletes on the planet and make
split-second decisions and reactions to
how they're reacting to you and people
feel that you can actually get there and
just be this big dumb guy I knew he
wasn't going to be dumb when I met him
and he wasn't so that was a that made
the [ __ ] that I was going to say about
him even better I mean I did one dumb
joke about it being dumb but I had to
get through it I had to do like [ __ ]
10 12 minutes so anyways it uh it went
great and my favorite part about it was
poppy yelled [ __ ] e with me at least
three or four times and I just kept
going [ __ ] you too man it's a roast you
wanted to get roasted here we go
and he was such a [ __ ] great guy the
guy really liked it was a rock star man
his whole vibe is a [ __ ] rock star so
when I finished he got up off the chair
and came over and gave me a big [ __ ]
hug and and thanked me for doing it just
gets really like one of the great
[ __ ] people I've ever gotten to do
something like that for so what was
funny is I had I had just as much I
think I had more jokes about Lenny Clark
than I did about poppy just because I
knew him which is why I always feel like
if you're going to do a roast you should
know the person and what's hilarious is
Lenny has been clean and sober for like
a
order of a century and all of my jokes
were about him just being a [ __ ] you
know complete mania lie I talked to him
basically like he wasn't sober like he
had been sober and he was you know the
best guy a great sport about it so
anyways long story short I got through
it I told you once I got through that
gig my the whole rest of my year [ __ ]
nothing easy easy easy easy peasy
everything's in my wheelhouse it's the
weirdest [ __ ] year for me I all the
crazy [ __ ] I had to do this month well
this year was all in this month all of
this stuff of just I haven't thought I
haven't said worried thinking how the
[ __ ] is this going to go this many times
in one month since back when I first
started out doing stand-up which
basically every show I was going up
thinking like [ __ ] commit to your [ __ ]
get that first laugh ride the wave don't
go over say goodnight get the [ __ ] out
of there you know so that's it and I'm
ready to go to the summer the next night
we all went to the game got to see the
retirement ceremony and it was great man
Jim Rice was there Carl Yastrzemski
Varitek Pedro Martinez Pedroia came out
and I got to see the whole thing then
they took the you know uncovered it got
to see when they were first put 34 up
there and I got to admit the part of it
was sad it was like [ __ ] it's over it's
over now he's part of the history of the
Boston Red Sox and I don't know though I
think you know all the ceremonies man it
was just remind you that you're going to
[ __ ] die my god now he's too old to
play baseball he's too old to [ __ ]
play and I'm like 15 years [ __ ] older
than he is a 10 years older than him you
know he'd call you stravsky coming out
with all white hair
I shouldn't know that was coming that
guy played until he was like [ __ ] 40
oh my god I'm nine years older than when
that guy retired maybe he played that
like forty three I don't [ __ ] know
this is getting depressing how do I get
out of this how the [ __ ] do I get out of
this oh I know
let's talk f1 and [ __ ] MotoGP big
wait big
all right so race number [ __ ] eight
or nine of the f1 season in Azerbaijan
is how they say Azerbaijan my Jan
whatever just eats of Georgia and I
don't mean [ __ ] Georgia United States
the country Georgia and I guess it's in
Asia it's not Eastern Europe I was it's
always weird Georgia and all the way
over there you don't know where the [ __ ]
they're at one of the coolest cities on
the f1 circuit using that word circuit
just a beautiful city I would love to go
there but I definitely looked up like is
that like one of those places I
shouldn't go so I have like a Canadian
[ __ ] flag on my backpack should I
speak in an Irish brogue would I go
there seemed like it was pretty safe I
don't know I don't [ __ ] know I had a
great time while crazy goddamn [ __ ]
race congratulations to Daniel Ricciardo
who I think might be the best driver in
f1
considering he doesn't have the best
engine and he's always on the [ __ ]
podium and he drinks champagne out of
his [ __ ] shoe so you know god bless
you and I don't know about this Lewis
Hamilton guy I was a fan I think he's a
[ __ ] great driver but I don't know
they said he didn't hit the brakes close
you guys don't watch that if they were
under caution the [ __ ] safety car was
out there you know guys always complain
that the safety car drives too [ __ ]
slow you know which cools off their
tires then they don't have any grip and
then they slam into the [ __ ] wall or
into each other right
so anyways Hamilton was complaining that
the [ __ ] guy was driving too slow and
then for whatever reason he hits the
brakes really hard in Sebastian Vettel
rear-ended him and he was like what the
[ __ ] and then he pedaled pulls up
alongside of him
and his cars and like you know tired
attire and he got a 10-second penalty
for that and I don't know I kind of view
it and they said Hamilton didn't slam on
the brakes but I kind of viewed this as
one of the ball don't lie you know they
say that basketball is some piece of
[ __ ] foul [ __ ] foul guy flops you go
up in and you missed the foul shots they
would say the ball don't lie well only
after that thing they said Hamilton slam
on the brakes
Hamilton and slam on the brakes and
Vettel was guilty of slamming into him
and the only game a 10-second penalty I
guess they said that should have been
more so B basically has to drive into
the [ __ ] pits and sit there for ten
seconds as everybody keeps going and
then drives back out again but Hamilton
after that that [ __ ] thing that goes
around his neck or whatever outside the
car that thing came loose so he had the
[ __ ] pull in any ways which [ __ ]
him over and Vettel still beat him so I
looked at that like the ball don't lie
and Hamilton [ __ ] I didn't like how he
[ __ ] said Deeks says to his team say
focus dude slow down he should slow down
so to help me backpedal go [ __ ] yourself
whatever last year when the team called
you up to slow down for [ __ ] a Nico
Rosberg and you like nah good you were
out there driving for yourself you know
what that guy reminds me of he reminds
me of a couple of comedians I'm not
going to [ __ ] mention their names
when I was on there whan my way up with
them and they were these [ __ ] people
they were happy if you got something as
long as they had more and they would
literally stab your mother in the eye if
they could get an inch forward that's
what I got out of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
he should slow down yo [ __ ] you got a
[ __ ] mercedes-benz engine that isn't
enough for you I still like Lewis
Hamilton but that was kind of girly that
was kind of girly I thought you know and
I mean I might be out of my [ __ ] mind
you I don't like that [ __ ] what I like
about f1 it's basically the [ __ ]
Mercedes and and the Ferraris okay if
you don't root for either one of those
other teams every other team it's like
they're out there driving around in a
[ __ ] z28 okay and Ferrari and
Mercedes they're driving around in a
Corvette zo6 seeing that Lance stroll he
was like 10 seconds ahead of
botas what happened to him an early part
of the race oh they're in Thai the
rights to everybody [ __ ] hit each
other in the beginning so he had to go
and he was immediately a lap down he's a
lap down he does his stroke or a [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] movie just flies through
the entire [ __ ] field I mean Daniel
Ricciardo did the same thing but he sees
in the Red Bull thing they got like
inferior engine like they won't give him
one of those Mercedes they won't sell
the guy a Mercedes or Ferrari engine
because he knows he he'd be too much of
a problem that's why I think he's the
best driver out there because he's
driving around basically a [ __ ] z28
and he's always up on the podium so
anyways for Scindia my [ __ ] team
there I don't know what's going on with
them they got this whole Ricky Bobby
Ricky Bobby [ __ ] going on slamming into
each other what the [ __ ] is wrong with
them
esteban olkhon and Sergio Perez they
basically took each other out of the
race they would have been on the podium
one possibly two cars and for half a
[ __ ] second where the tea the hot
steam the [ __ ] American team
Magnussen was like in third place all
right
two of the Williams it was the craziest
[ __ ] race like the front of the race
with Daniel Ricciardo like both Williams
martini martini embracing whatever the
[ __ ] you say it and Magnussen then of
course they all just get run down they
all get [ __ ] run down both tests was
like ten seconds behind stroll with like
ten laps to go and he [ __ ] caught him
right at the finish line to get second
place so that's it I can no longer root
for [ __ ] Ferrari and I can't root for
Mercedes because I feel like I'm rooting
for the Yankees of the Red Sox ever
reason why root for the Red Sox is
because I'm from Boston what am I
supposed to do but like you know they
both blow 200 million dollars but not
this year the Yankees happen but I'm
just saying generally speaking
throughout history right so I can't I
can't like pile on pull a Kevin Durant
or a LeBron down in Miami or the big
three in Boston two out of three anyways
I can't [ __ ] do that so my team my
teams I like I like the force
the India team and I like the the
Williams racing team that's the coolest
looking car I think I like that colors
you know red white and blue I guess they
used to dominate the line I got to read
up more on this sport I don't get how
you used to [ __ ] dominate and
everything you just suck you know I
don't get it it's not like other sports
where you got athletes getting old and
dying not dying retiring I should say I
mean if you know how to make a [ __ ]
engine work at that level shouldn't you
just know how to do it I know I know the
driver does count for something but gee
I don't [ __ ] know what I'm saying I
don't know [ __ ] about this stuff I just
know it's fun to watch
I guess Red Bull won like three in a row
like I don't five six years ago and then
all of a sudden what engine were they
using then I'm afraid to I'm afraid to
look it up and it'll be like [ __ ] P's
and Q's and no I'll have an answer so I
watched that today and then I also
watched the the MotoGP race which was
[ __ ] insane both races were great the
MotoGP race was even [ __ ] better like
it's crazy is that race was that they
have a problem with that
Azerbaijan race where because it goes to
a city they don't have those cranes to
lift the cars out of the way and it's
[ __ ] debris all over the track they
actually had a red flag and everybody
just pulled in and just stopped as all
these guys were running around the track
picking up [ __ ] from other cars that had
smashed into each other as crazy as that
race was the MotoGP race was was the
[ __ ] Valentino Rossi it's like 38
[ __ ] years old he ended up winning
the thing just imagine all the [ __ ]
that was happened f1 with them bumping
into each other they're doing it on
motorcycles going like 150 200 [ __ ]
miles an hour you know the guy like the
best on I mean I always root for
Valentino Rossi just cuz he's old and I
relate and I want him to keep winning so
it doesn't make me feel like you know
when he retires if I god there's another
guy I like that Johan Johan
zharko that guy's a [ __ ] lunatic and
I also like the color the bike the black
and the yellow whatever they got
I like him I like and then I also like
the Ducati team I like that I say his
last name dou V dou dava COC didn't Co
so I can't say it I can't say someone's
gotta say I gotta watch another 15 races
to be able to pronounce that do viz io s
o zo so though Dobie Dovizioso Dovizioso
said I said German Irish like we usually
have two syllable one syllable [ __ ]
last names I can't that's that's too
many [ __ ] Hills Dovizioso aundrea
Dovizioso grazie prego
just an incredible [ __ ] race Mack
marques was in there too and then that
[ __ ] lunatic the British guy Cal
Crutchlow I don't know where the [ __ ] he
came from that guy rides like a Lulu the
way he wrote in yo hands Arco I like
that they're out of their [ __ ] minds
so I'm all in on both of those races
they're so [ __ ] easy to watch
twenty something laps and then the the
one today with the cars was like watch
like 50 [ __ ] laughs 51 it's a good
goddamn time and then after that I take
my daughter out you know a lot of people
when they want to get their babies to
fall asleep a lot of dads what they do
is they put them in the car and they
drive around it's hilarious because the
movement makes them go to sleep but then
you get to a red light and they wake up
and they start crying again that's why I
am a big proponent of the stroller all
right because you can keep that [ __ ]
the indicator red light you can keep it
you know if you're walking and also it's
a great way to prevent the dreaded
dadbod okay all you [ __ ] guys out
there you throw them in the car and then
you drive around you know then they fall
asleep and then what do you do you hit
the drive-thru because you're tired you
know RVs we have the meats and then you
get that [ __ ] sandwich that also has
a pig on it the pork the spareribs or
whatever the [ __ ] they put on there for
the ribs the hoof the hoof
yeah I've been just walking her around
my neighborhood and she falls asleep and
then I just keep walking throughout her
whole nap I went to the [ __ ] butcher
went to the supermarket knock out some
errands as she's asleep you just keep it
[ __ ] moving the whole time he throw
the groceries on the bottom of the
stroller and that's it there's a little
dad tip for you you got he got a better
one I don't know what to tell you I do
the elliptical while she's still
sleeping in the morning and I take her
for a trip around the neighborhood you
got to do it you can't you can't do the
car thing then you got to go out and
walk put on your track suits right
tracks you see dad's socks
you [ __ ] jean shorts whatever the
[ __ ] you got going on you're true
religion jeans I love that I never gave
in to that fed those are the Z
cavariccis the [ __ ] last decade giant
stitching with the [ __ ] you want to
get lucky boy [ __ ] horseshoe on the
back there was always something funny
about a horseshoe in the ass pockets
that always to me was more gay pride
parade than [ __ ] Haley they were
[ __ ] chicks over there but they [ __ ]
they love them they love them and
speaking of [ __ ] the gay pride parade
you know it's slowly making a comeback
and I love it because I never had a
problem with it is rollerblading
rollerblading is slowly making a
comeback I loved it I used to go down
the beach with my short shorts on
skating backwards getting a little boy
short True Religion boy shorts I did it
we share we all did it there's the photo
shop for the week but you know what
there's no [ __ ] true religion boy
shorts the good luck with you on that
one [ __ ] oh no I liked it I used to play
[ __ ] in New York and out in Santa
Monica Ennis Beach I used to play roller
hockey and Jesus Christ catching an edge
never hurt more than when you were in a
[ __ ] parking lot you had to go elbow
pads you had to do it elbow and knee
pads you just had to [ __ ] do it
you know out there dressed like Robocop
because when you went down you work you
will [ __ ] the only have sucked is the
hockey gloves you didn't have that thing
and I actually broke my wrist or broke a
bone in my wrist I used to his eye his
oh my god way back way way way back
way back in the [ __ ] day I used to
play 2-1 to rollerblade hockey at the
two on the top of parking garages in
West Hollywood I used to play it with
three other comics it was me and Dane
Cook it was verses through all Boston
comics versus Rick Thalia and wrested so
peak coming and I remember we used to
remember playing the day of the Super
Bowl just laughing and how insane the
[ __ ] weather was it was eighty
degrees out we went out there had a
great [ __ ] game super super highly
competitive [ __ ] game and we used to
play at the top of the parking garage
because for whatever reason on like the
Sundays or whatever they would just
never there would be enough people no
wanted to park on the roof because the
car would get all [ __ ] hot on the
inside and we would play up there and
sometimes someone will park up there but
no one would ever rat us out and only a
couple of times did the ball ever go
over the edge that I remember but we
always had like an extra one but I would
do that all the time and it was a great
time and I never understood why the
whole [ __ ] fad went away there was
one homophobic joke one homophobic joke
killed me what's the hardest thing about
rollerblading telling your parents
telling telling your parents that you're
gay that one little joke the whole
[ __ ] thing the whole thing went away
I never understood it I got to the point
I was the one that the guy who took his
brake off that was like a big thing when
you lived in New York you had to be cool
you had to take your brake off and learn
how to stop the other way like yeah why
would I want to be able to stop quick
when I'm skating out in traffic with
cabs and [ __ ] I can't believe I never
died I had a couple of really close
calls so [ __ ] stupid I would never do
that again I just chalk that up to being
young like I still lived in New York and
I was close to
Central Park Clark market park and I was
going to go rollerblading
I would I would at this my age I would
walk to the park carrying my [ __ ]
rollerblades I have no shame about it I
know a lot of people are embarrassed
that they rollerblade it I have no
[ __ ] shame no shame if I live closer
to a boardwalk I would own a pair and I
would go out there it's so much more fun
than doing the [ __ ] elliptical it's
better exercise you know you put on your
wireless headphones right you tie your
t-shirt off at the waist and you know
you go out there and you you have a good
time maybe you have some tassels on I
don't know why I am I I think it's
hilarious that everybody got all [ __ ]
weird about it as you can tell I haven't
read any advertising I haven't done any
[ __ ] questions because I'm recording
it early and I still haven't got my
materials for the week let's hit refresh
see if they came in let's see nothing
nothing nothing no advertising no
nothing alright I'll keep talking here
I'll keep talking I'll read the ads and
then I'll do the [ __ ] I'll do the
[ __ ] uh what do you call it do the
questions alright alright no dad bought
I already talked about that Oh Billy no
fun Billy no fun
Billy no fun didn't drink until Friday
night took my nephew to the game and
after I dropped him off I went back into
the city and I had a to home pours and a
[ __ ] anise in a cigar but then I
didn't drink last night
and today I had one course like just
because they may be old stubby bottles
again I just had to add one and it was
[ __ ] delicious but I don't count that
I just had one I think it's [ __ ] up
anyways so I've been doing that [ __ ] got
the drinking back under control and I'm
going to find out this week by the way
if there's going to be a season 3 of
efforts for family so I'm a little
nervous to find out so
if you haven't watched it yet it would
really help us if you guys would watch
this week to give a nice little boost
you know I know there's a ton of good
[ __ ] out there I know bloodline came
back I know some of you guys are working
your way through Fargo or better call
Saul but uh you can just give us just
you know watch one episode something
anything will help because we're going
to find out this week and so anyways I
went to the Red Sox Friday night
Saturday I came home and the Angels game
was on against the Red Sox because you
know I get the angels feed out here and
now back into watching baseball I'm
watching racing and I actually watched
the end of the BC Eagles versus the
Edmonton Eskimos I watched a CFL game I
got to tell you it was highly
entertaining because the BC Eagles
[ __ ] defense sucks one of those
high-scoring games or whatever they tied
it up and then you know what ended up
with like no time left and the Edmonton
Eskimos go out in the first [ __ ] play
they gave up I don't know a nice 80 yard
meter whatever the [ __ ] they call it a
kilometer or whatever they call it up
their pass and then they lost the game
kicked a field goal and it was over and
a lot of people [ __ ] on the CFL it's on
TSN it's good [ __ ] you know I look at it
this way this is college players that
weren't good enough to make it you know
into the end of the NFL but any one of
those CFL teams could beat the best
[ __ ] college team out there because
it's made of college all-stars like the
NFL it's college all-stars the NFL is
just the best of the best college
all-stars the CFL is all called
all-stars that could not make it to the
NFL so it's still competitive football
they got that giant field I actually
enjoyed it I don't know I always watch
like the Edmonton Eskimos just because
like way back in the day tour we seemed
like Doug Flutie and Warren Moon or some
[ __ ] we're always on those teams but you
know I don't know BC Eagles came back so
I was like I had a head watching I'm
gonna root for these guys and they [ __ ]
the game up I don't know what else to
talk about I'm running out of [ __ ]
congratulations to the lady in in
Australia who breastfed in durin in
Parliament I don't know why that was a
big deal but evidently it's a big deal I
don't know I have to be honest with you
my whole [ __ ] life I've never heard
one guy ever say that he had an issue
with breastfeeding in public I don't
know what the [ __ ] problem is I think
it's more for like guys that don't have
kids yet and it like grosses amount
because they're like I want to be
sticking my face in there now there's a
baby there and that weirds me out
it makes my chubby go away I don't know
what the deal is I also don't think I'd
be honest with you I don't think you
should be breastfeeding while you're
[ __ ] you know working for your
district you know can we have your 100%
focus here you know I don't know I bet I
guess guys to go up then adjust their
balls is there talking about laws I
don't know I don't know why I don't know
what the big deal is about it I've seen
it my whole [ __ ] life but I also
don't know why it's treated like
somebody just landed on Mars and came
back you know anything women do is now
it's just like it was so great you know
they try to act like you know they were
they were in Braveheart it's like you
fed a baby because it was hungry running
on a ship to talk about royal blood has
a new album out everybody
now I didn't download their first one I
just downloaded their hit and I played
my drums to a thousand times and I still
suck at it you know that something
something to do but but I do gotta
[ __ ] work it out
wham bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bluh
bluh bluh
Farah do whatever you got to do to boo
however the [ __ ] song goes I don't
even know the words Wham when did it BAM
why did it boo royal blood as a new
album out and it got good reviews so I'm
going to download that [ __ ] because I
have a [ __ ] I got a little rehearsal
space I was over there today was over
there today I got my [ __ ] life down
it's perfect wake up in the morning I
work out right while the kids sleep in
my wife's sleep and then I run over I
play drums for a [ __ ] hour
come back like a champ and make
everybody breakfast you know I get my
[ __ ] done and then in the afternoon
I take my [ __ ] precious little baby
girl for a walk that's it that's it but
you know what my wife will still find
something to complain to me about
something
Oh something they'll be something up
they went wrong I just feel like I would
like it better if you I feel like for me
all right this is the last thing that I
got to hit pause until this [ __ ] [ __ ]
comes in the questions here come on man
send the [ __ ] questions
refresh button hit the refresh button
bill hit the refresh button nothing
wait a minute I'm an [ __ ] I was in
the wrong account what an [ __ ] what
that is the kind of guy doesn't know the
difference between photosynthesis and
pollination fighting out of the blue
corner here we go oh and lo and behold
there it is
there we go it's time for some
advertising I was just going to give you
guys a fun baseball fact remind me when
I come back you can't but oh you know
all right
oh but do me on these neon DS they used
to be two all-star games doo doo doo doo
biondi's biondi's between 1959 1962 and
everybody went up to plate their balls
hurt they didn't know what to do because
the suits were made of wool they didn't
have that one sucked I got to take two
on that one I tried to give you the
ultimate allstar games in 1959-60 61 and
I believe 62 I might as well give it to
you now right I'll tell it to you why
not you know why it is do you know why
they had two all-star games not because
you know people couldn't afford to
travel so they had one on the East Coast
one of the west coast it wasn't that it
wasn't happy okay turns out that playing
of the second game was intended to
increase the amount of money going to
the players pension fund this person
says I wish there was a neater reason
than that like gambling demand
or trial formation of an all-stars
league which would be made up of two
teams of all-stars that played each
other 100 times a season but no pension
fund that's it and everybody realized by
1962 or so that the arrangement was dumb
the public at large is finding a second
all-star game something of an
anti-climax like playing a second World
Series in Brazil so 1951 1960 61 1959
sorry 60 61 they played two all-star
games there you go
I learned that this weekend when I saw a
pennant from Fenway about the 1961
all-star games and they called the
Cincinnati Reds by the way the red Lakes
which I had never heard of either hey
Bill why don't you get to the
advertising because that was some of the
most boring [ __ ] I've ever listened to
in my life hey hey hey
fair enough oh don't do me andhis me
undies mind you [ __ ] queues and peas
to do to me undies me undies I can't
[ __ ] sing it this week
I got nothing this week that brain is
fried for right now let's roast roast I
thought if I was ended with peas and
gave me some rides the under you candies
mind your [ __ ] P's and Q's
doo-doo-doo-doo me undies me on these
don't pee pee or do the doo doo and your
[ __ ] valve is [ __ ] underwear
if you shed no one will care because
it'll be soft and cradled yeah in the
teen of your phone that's close all
right me undies everybody talk about why
you think it's important to have great
underwear well because it doesn't ride
up on your balls and dick there you
perfected your wardrobe but what about
the stuff everybody every not everybody
gets to sees see sorry if you've been
settling for store-bought underwear five
packs I have something that will change
your life for the better it's me undies
everyone what's the first thing you put
on the last thing you take off its your
underwear unless you're Matthew
McConaughey make your most important
piece of clothing the best it can be
with me undies what is me undies ah yes
seriously soft feel-good undies
delivered right to your front door the
undies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro motile modal a
fabric
softer than cotton why don't we clean
out our ears with it then me and I'll
wipe our ass with it I mean if you're
telling me that this [ __ ] is better than
cotton well cos cotton is natural the
undies softer than soft luxury undies
come in an ever-changing selection of
classic colors bold shades and
adventurous plat patterns so you can
tailor your undies to your own personal
style and guess what you can save time
and money each month with a monthly
subscription if you're not ready for
ascription that's okay min you can still
save that's because the undies is
offering 20% off your first pair just
use our special URL me undies comm slash
burn get 20% off your first pair once
again that's me undies calm / / hey my
undies calm / / oh I love it there's
only three or four reads this week all
right Alex Hilux you're unique you're a
special little [ __ ] snowflake you
don't walk like everyone else talk like
everyone else sure shed sleep light for
everyone else so why is your mattress
one size fits all because a truly
customized mattress will cost you five
to ten thousand dollars until now go to
hell its sleep calm Felix
answer a few simple questions and
they'll run a 3d biomechanical model of
your body through their proprietary
algorithms they developed with the help
of the world's leading oregano mix
biomechanics experts the result the most
comfortable mattress you've ever slept
on helix Hellas customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality and
four couples for [ __ ] sweat they
customize each side of the mattress so
you can [ __ ] your you can [ __ ] somebody
else and while your partner's still
sleeping your mattress arrives at your
door in about a week and the shipping is
100% free
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helix sleep
calm you'll you have 100 nights to try
it out and if you don't love it they'll
pick it up for free gross and give you
100% refund no questions asked
yes go to hell it's leat calm / / and
get $50 off your order that helix sleep
calm / /
hellix leap calm / burst spelled h e li
x Dollar Shave Club dude
Dollar Shave Club is this not a choice I
talked to this guy this weekend he had
like one of those Boston accent said it
sounds like he's slurring I'll try to
recreate it you'll get a gray shave and
a great price conveniently delivered
right to you do I know you no longer
have to schlep to the store to buy a
cheap disposable razor that gives you a
cheap shave dude I spend a fortune on
wages with gimmick I can't even do it
gimmicky shaving technology you don't
even need and when you used a Dollar
Shave club's executive razor with their
doctor Kavi the blade just gently glides
giving you a smooth shave dr. carver
shea butter is transparent for a more
precise shave helps prevent ingrown
hairs and feels great on your balls make
the smarter choice by joining Dollar
Shave Club for a limited time new
members can get their first month of the
executive razor with the tube of carving
cheesy Schabel only five dollars off
well for only $5 with free shipping
after that razors are just a few dollars
a month that's a $15 value for only 5
bucks there are no hidden fees no
commitments cancel anytime you like you
can only get this offer exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com one more for God's
sakes our old friends should old
acquaintance be forgot and their copy
not be read
stamps.com stamp save you time and money
but you can use to grow your business
you can mail any letter any package
using just your computer or printer and
the mailman comes and picks it up that's
right the mailman he's not breastfeeding
while he walks to the goddamn mailbox
he's grabbing his balls walking right up
to walk avoid the hassle man of the post
office to mail everything from postcards
to envelopes to packages domestic or
international create your stamps account
in minutes
with no equipment to lease and no
long-term commitments unlike the post
office
stamps.com never closes print postage or
letters or packaged for what print
postage for letters or packages at your
cat your convenience 24/7 keywords
descriptions convenient easy reliable
flexible
stamps.com brings all the service of the
u.s. post office right to your
fingertips buying and print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and printer no need to lease an
expensive postage meter I use stamps
comm anytime I'm selling posters
afterwards my after my shows if I want
to or myself out if I can figure it out
god damn it you can too and right now
you too can enjoy Stan's calm service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale without long-term
commitment go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in BER that stamps.com enter
birth thank frigging God I'm done with
that [ __ ] I hate doing a lot of reads
during the summer alright here we go
let's read some of the content some of
the content oh hey I got I got a promote
a Paul Bercy show Paul virzi with the
hilarious Mike Fay vermin our
co-headlining a comedy show to help
raise awareness to fight that's film
intervening getting high team say Jesus
Christ has a [ __ ] mouthful is a
nonprofit that helps young adolescents
tell inspiring stories through film and
video creations that helped curb the
opiate epidemic founded by oxymoron
writers often morons writer / director
Johnny Hickey ever seen that movie
that's a good one check that one out
they're doing the show at the kowloon on
route 1 in Saugus this Thursday July
29th 7:00 to 10:00 p.m. free buffet with
ticket purchase of $40 alright go to the
kowloon route 1 saga some of the best
[ __ ] Chinese food you're ever going
to have Pulver Zi Mike Fay vermin I'm
going to [ __ ] kill it 7 and 10 p.m.
what 7 7 - 10 p.m. it is 2 shows 1 show
ten I don't know what it is look it up
all right Kowloon route one Saugus
all right three drink rule Hey Bilbo bag
hits I have three drinks tonight and
went home I feel great about myself from
a fellow adult ooh little shade there in
the end I don't know dude three drinks
you'll become a bloated fat [ __ ] he had
three drinks and then you drove home
what kind of drinks all right here's one
for you buddy I drank probably over 300
days last year I don't feel good about
myself and me needing to shut it down in
no way should make you feel
self-conscious about what you're doing
to the point you have to be kunti to me
and say you feel great about yourself
all right that's it so good for you keep
having three drinks tonight and feeling
good about yourself when you don't feel
good about yourself shut it down you
know what I'll do all cancer charity
sham oh here we go here we go here's
another one there's another one in a
rare joint action with attorney
attorneys general for each of the 50
states the Federal Trade Commission says
for cancer charities run by extended
members of the same family con donors
out of a hundred and eighty seven
million dollars from 2008 through 2012
and spent almost nothing to help actual
cancer patients and what happens to
these people they're going to go to jail
Children's Cancer Fund all right let's
see
in a rare of above IRA each of the
charities charged with the subject of
extensive reporting by CNN and 2013 are
because I remember the story and in each
instance none of the four charities
would comment we were ordered out of the
building at the Cancer Fund of America
in Knoxville Tennessee home of the
Tennessee volunteer and where the object
of an obscene gesture by the CEO of the
Breast Cancer Society am i that's
usually that's usually a good sign that
it's [ __ ] if you're raising money to
for cancer foot out to help kids
stricken with cancer and you're the CEO
and you give the finger of media which
is going to help promote yeah that's
probably a good sign
the Cancer Fund of America is run by
James Reynolds senior his son James
Reynolds jr. this is all alleged by the
way before these scumbags allegedly
start to sue me for eveness is the CEO
of the Breast Cancer Society another
charity the child's Cancer Fund of
America is run by Rose Perkins the
ex-wife of the elder James Reynolds he's
also the CEO of the fourth charity
cancer support supports of services Wow
Wow well if they're doing dirt I hope
they get caught and they go to [ __ ]
jail Jesus Christ man that is like some
sociopath [ __ ] Jesus Christ oh my god
you're going out buying like a [ __ ]
when I buy yourself a raptor like a
[ __ ] what could you be is something
for you what could you buy yourself with
with cancer [ __ ] that was supposed to go
to help kids what could you buy yourself
oh my god that that is I mean that is
just at it's just that's on another
[ __ ] level I think even bankers would
be like really do Jesus Christ how about
a little [ __ ] little bit attacked
something all right transgender habits a
Billy muffin tops that's so true I
listened to ng yeah a few months ago
maybe even a few years ago oh Jesus
sorry losing credibility I came over the
last month or 2010 I heard a segment you
might be interested in I believe it was
this American Life but they asked a
transgendered man I don't think a woman
becoming a man I get it I think if there
was any interesting changing well he
talked about after his transition
he was now more into science was way
more interested in sex and wasn't able
to access his emotions as much anymore
oh so those are basically guy things
that's kind of interesting
I would think way more interested in sex
because you're finally a sex you want to
be science that's really interesting and
weren't able to access your emotions
more I don't know I have no idea that's
well there you go so maybe I wasn't
wrong thinking that somebody's habits
changed female privilege hey man I love
your podcasts hope your family's doing
great thank you thank you very much
wasn't that nice of you the family is
doing great my daughter is awesome and
my wife I have a whole new level love
for watching a be a mom no have a read
at this article when you get a chance
okay female nurse found guilty of
dangerous driving causing death to be
sentenced do I want to read this there
aren't any kids involved in the system
we already saw a potential scam okay BC
nurse found guilty of dangerous driving
causing death sentenced to 90 days in
jail the families of two young people
are angry over a dangerous driving
sentence giving the woman who killed
them okay the BC nurse found guilty of
Danish driving causing death of two
people's been sentenced to 90 days in
jail and Alina Hesse mobic was driving
at high speeds through pet pit meadows
and knocked over 2010 she ran a red
light jumped a concrete median and
slammed into a car carrying Becky Dyer
19 and Johnny D Oliveira 21 the couple
who were on their way home from a
concert were killed instantly
along with the 90-day sentence Essie
mobic also received two years provoque
probation 120 hours of community service
in three years driving probation she
will serve her sentence intermittently
between Tuesdays and Thursdays around
her work schedule oh my god what a joke
Dyer's mother Debbie said this sentence
is not showing the public that our
justice system actually is a justice
system it's actually a legal system it's
not going to deter other drivers from
doing the same oh my god Dee olivera's
mom
Audrey echoed the same sentiment six
years is a long time she's put everybody
through and she's only getting a little
bit here a little bit there it's wrong a
that's terrible that's [ __ ] terrible
[Music]
that's [ __ ] horrible you know at some
point when you're driving that fast you
do I mean I think those laws are all
going to change I know they have with
drunk driving I think because she wasn't
drunk and jails are all filled up at
least in this country like I don't
understand that but I mean your life
should be tremendously affected if you
would if you were driving that [ __ ]
fast and then killed two innocent people
I think the whole well she's never
committed a crime she's a nurse she's a
productive member of society a lot of
that goes out the [ __ ] window well
she did something tremendously stupid
enough to people are dead forever
so at the very least you can do 90
straight days in jail what do you say
there and yeah I guess you'll have to
figure out what you're going to fight
you gonna find another job after that
what kind of cool job does she have I
have to be on jail I think jail on
Tuesday and Thursdays because I killed
two people on Tuesday I go to jail for
the woman I killed on Thursday I go to
jail for the guy I killed so like can I
work like Monday not Wednesday so it'll
be like so tired for me in jail for one
day I work like Monday Friday Saturday
and a half day Sunday that's yeah that's
disgusting
[ __ ] disgusting all right my
girlfriend is becoming a feminist they
their daddy bald freckle first of all
English is isn't my mother tongue so
sorry if I [ __ ] up a bit all right
it's morning why that I could just see
you googling daddy bald freckle and just
mashing him us what I would have done
all right and I'm 33 years old and I'm
an 18 and 18 months relationship with a
terrific girl after four rather
unsuccessful relationship I finally had
the feeling she could be the one
she has her flaws like every person but
hey so do I when it comes down to the
important features like honesty moral
values similar lifestyles and interests
she really is my match and to top it all
up in bed it never gets boring dude this
is your second language this is great
she's more on the submissive side maybe
you're just [ __ ] with me and you
deliberately wrote a bad insult she's
more than the cement aside if you
understand wink and some things
sometimes get wild grow Rose I now have
no sympathy for you
but in a very nice way he tries to say
after our sexy time session gross we lay
next to each other come completely out
of breath feeling like nothing can touch
us sounds cheesy but it's really good
look why did you go into all that detail
oh my god that was disgusting never tell
you guys how much I can't stand watching
people kiss in public on film arena it's
it's the grossest [ __ ] thing ever
look keep your intimacy's to yourself
now we have a long-distance relationship
we are far away but we still each to see
you still see each other quite often
five times per year but then usually
weeks at a time - what the [ __ ] just
happened what the hell just happen it
was a was there a jump in time here was
there some time travel going on here
she lives in Europe and has been hanging
out with these feminist activist girls
and she's bringing up the topic of
sexism etc more and more lately now I
was raised by a proud mother of Jesus is
there any other kind perhaps strong
woman and could not imagine dating a
girl that has has values of women out of
the 1950's I like confident proud women
this is what he always sets himself up
to be a good guy that can hold their own
but even though I am NOT a chauvinist by
any means
I think the modern feminist movement
similar to vegans annoying the living
annoys the living hell out of me
I get that there is sexism in this world
but I don't see the huge problem in it
especially since the Western societies
have made such
yes in this field in the past decades
yeah I mean I don't know you keep
talking yourself back into the hole
there yeah like a total psycho
100% feminist maniac yet you don't be
around that it's literally like being
around a conspiracy theorist after a
while as far as they're never going to
shut the [ __ ] up about that topic it's
going to drive you nuts after a while do
you realize every day 40% of women they
can be thrown stats at you like someone
plays fantasy football anyway he says
today my girlfriend sent me a link to an
article about how pornography
objectifies and discriminate women then
she wrote I've been thinking a lot
lately and how to change some things in
the future especially in our sex life
yeah dude this relationship is over now
I tend to agree with Knight endovenous
Auto but nevertheless I furiously
replied hey if you're going to turn into
one of these non stop nagging feminists
please tell me now so I can even move
the [ __ ] further away from you and your
victims seeking miserable friends yeah
dude yeah you're kind of an [ __ ]
you're kind of an [ __ ] slash a bit of
a control freak I think I don't know but
then you're cool too moving away I don't
I can't read you he goes then things
escalated quickly yeah you think we got
into a big fight and haven't
communicated since yeah dude it's a wrap
it was already a wrap it was already a
wrap you know if you just imagine if you
got into something okay and then you
came home and whatever your new [ __ ]
way of thinking was you told your wife
that your girlfriend that she needed to
adjust some things in the bedroom I mean
try that one on for size yeah what it is
is she's grown in a different direction
and she needs to be you know I know
she's with a different type of guy not
you now bill this is a girl this girl is
great and smart and tbh I don't what
that means I am all for women's rights
and see sexism on a daily basis and
totally understand some of them stop
[ __ ] making yourself out to be the
hero oh no one of these guys but I'm not
wise so leave me the [ __ ] alone with
this stuff
and if this stuff will interfere with
our sex life and change the woman that I
have learned to love I don't know where
this will leave us what do you think of
this am I being too non empathetic here
it's been I don't think you're an
empathetic person I would say that yeah
this is a wrap this is not the kind of
woman you're looking for and this is a
major change in her all right I mean I
don't know what goes on between the two
of you but if she's going to be like hey
watch this and we need to change some
stuff in the bedroom like the
relationship as you know it is over
and in its long distance I mean yes it's
a [ __ ] wrap I would walk away all
right [ __ ] up at pet shop
last one here [ __ ] up at the pet shop
he's been Milan Angelina West and girls
pet shop boys that's right [ __ ] up at
pet shop how's it going old Billy
Bordeaux bollocks
love the podcast Congrats okay thank you
very much all the great work on f is for
family baggies too haven't left at
anything so hard in long time old Billy
I [ __ ] up recently but no one knows
I've done anything wrong I work in a pet
shop we sell rabbits and mice things
like that and my job is to feed them and
clean their cages I already don't like
where this is going
not the most exciting thing in the world
I love animals and they look so sad a
lot of the time so I try to make their
lives a little better by looking after
them the best I can
that's what I would do if I worked at a
pet store long story short I'm fairly
new so the first day I was taught how to
tell the male rabbits from the female
rabbits turns out you have to feel for
the testicles which wasn't that hard as
a lot of the rabbits had really big
balls like holy [ __ ] and I was pretty
confident that I could do it in the
future
god these are weird this week fast
forward to Monday turns out I cannot do
it we've got a whole load of new
Lionhead rabbits in with massive fur
making it almost impossible to locate
the balls well just flick them between
the legs if the rabbits are
like what the [ __ ] was that for it she
has a [ __ ] if you [ __ ] flick it
between the legs and the thing collapses
you know and lays there for 30 seconds
while his other friends laugh at him
that that is a male and the ones
laughing well women laugh at that [ __ ]
too anyways at that stage it was just me
and one of the student part-time workers
who probably had just learned to locate
his own balls let alone someone else's
why is this a big deal well I can tell
you I think you can figure out we can
why we can't put the males in with the
females bill I seriously don't know what
the [ __ ] happened but I went home that
evening having no idea if I was going to
arrive back into work would double the
number of rabbits I know that's not how
gestation works but [ __ ] it what would
you do if you were in my situation I
just started working here and I really
liked it but I have no idea how explain
how I [ __ ] this up so badly thanks for
what happened we got a whole new load of
new Lionhead rabbits in with massive fur
making those applause so what is it what
is the problem here you're worried that
you're going to put them in with the
wrong ones in a cap [ __ ] oh my god I
just dropped my [ __ ] laptop on my
foot
Jesus Christ I don't know what the
problem is sir
what I would do is I would come clean
before you have 7,000 rabbits and they
got to feed them to the snakes that's
what I would do all right
how hard is it to find [ __ ] balls I
put on a glove then I under Neath them
you know that it attended to put it
about it I don't know I don't know what
you're on am i I'm out of my element I
don't know what to tell you I don't know
how to find rabbit balls I would
definitely come clean and say that you
think you [ __ ] messed up because the
fact that you're running from this
problem like that guy in Fargo
oh geez I'm going to get you the numbers
like you're doing that right now all
right and I'm afraid you're going to end
up blaming the [ __ ] college student
all right so I would just come clean say
that you [ __ ] up I don't think they're
going to fire you over it you know what
I mean
that's what I would do and I would learn
how to find rabbit balls I'm getting to
another line of business all right okay
there you go that's the podcast for this
week I'll check in on Thursday if you'd
like to contribute to this podcast just
go to Netflix and watch f is for family
this week if you don't want to do that
go to my podcast page click on the my
website click on the podcast page and
you're going to buy something on Amazon
just click on the Amazon link it takes
you there I get credit for driving
traffic and they kick me a little doremi
over there ok that's it don't [ __ ]
yourselves and I will talk to you on
Thursday